hello guys were here to talk about
episode 4 the Warriors of Kyoshi
hopefully I'm saying that right and
something interesting happened on this
episode you know my my brother his wife
gave a call and they say hey we're we're
throwing dinner together did you want to
come over I said I'd love to but I gotta
edit and I also got a watch I gotta
watch the avatar and do the V walk for
it and they said oh why don't you come
on over and we'll watch it you know
we're having a mom and dad over to I'm
like what but they want to watch avatar
baby I don't know so I said I'll be over
a little later I go over there and
they're finishing up Episode three of
Avatar and I come in and I'm like well I
gotta watch Episode four and they're
like let's put it on where we're liking
it so now my folks are interested in
avatar which who the hell would have
thought yeah uh I guess it's the show
that brings families together a little
caption for you there uh so yeah once
again I guess it goes sort of beyond the
typical expectations of just being a
kids show which a like it shows too but
it's it's cool that this one can again I
don't see any attraction to it more and
more so with that said this episode I'll
tell you what I really enjoyed about
this episode is I sort of been going on
and on about the the comedy in these
shows being a little too childish but
again I get it kids show you got a trade
uh
this is the first one where it was like
legitimately funny like this was not
only make me laugh it was making me
laugh hard like there were good jokes in
this and good character based jokes as
my skype um but just just a lot of good
stuff in this one uh uh and I'll tell
you the one that made me laugh the most
okay so just the set up I'm sure you all
know but this is the one where um they
travel to this I think it's an island
I'm not sure but but this this land
where they have one of the avatars
reincarnations used to be their way
whatever centuries ago uh and he comes
there and he's he
reveals who he is and he gets a lot of
fangirls essentially this is a very
female dominated society and and the
Warriors are female and so forth and the
see after one of the things he's trying
to do is that he's trying to show off
this trick to the sister where it's just
something very simple he's just going
like this and making a little out of
what is a little wheel spin or something
like that and we finally reveals who he
is um he says now take a look at this
and he does that trick again and this
one guy just like screams at the top of
his lungs like a girl just well it's
sounding that the mouth that just falls
over and it's oh we have to watch it
like three times to get the laughs out
it was so funny um but I'm topping it
the other humor in this is so strong
they have one scene it starts out with
them trying to figure out where the
avatar is and looks like he's jumping
over from you know nation nation place
to place and you know the Prince looks
it looks as as obviously as avatar is
the master of uh III don't know
outwitting us or something like that
idea remembers a Khloe says but it turns
out he just wants to go different parts
to either have fun like riding animals
or they just get lost I think after he
says they cuts to them and he just as we
are so lost and that was very funny and
the humor on this one was really on
track but a really another great thing
about it is that um they have a set up
for what this episode is going to be
about uh you know they sit all the
fangirls are over the avatar and they
say yeah and the sister says but don't
let it go to your head oh I won't okay
well we know what this episode is might
as well just go the next one cuz we know
what it is but no they do the lesson in
there it's definitely there
but they address it very quickly and
then they move on they move on to other
issues going on like there's a scene
that the the fire army comes and of
course the Airbender has to fight them
off protect the villa
but he's seen the damage that has
happened from him just being there I
think it's being revealed that the
responsibility of just being who he is
is gonna be a lot to take on and you can
see it just by the way he's looking down
over the village that's burning uh and
that's done without words that's only
done through the music and the shots and
the expression drawn on the face again
for a kid show to get that that's very
impressive um another thing I like about
this episode is that you probably heard
me say before that I kinda get I mean
the it's legit point but I can't get
annoyed when they do a lot of like the
you know the girl power thing in the
sense of oh come on girls can't do that
girls can't be there oh yeah they stand
up to the big dumb society and prove
them wrong you know fair enough there's
a lot of prejudice but you know I've
seen it to death
here I think it works a little better
because it's not the society that
against you know females being you know
pretty much the wires in this it's this
one idiot
it's the brother and the brother catches
on very quickly to a point where he even
wants to be taught by them and it's not
done just for left he does it very
respectively he boughs to them and says
I would very much like to learn your
ways and again it's not just a one no
character it does show that he will
learn from his mistakes and he wants to
grow stronger from that I think that's a
very good thing to have in this I mean
to a point where he even has to wear the
uniforms you know which are very
feminine but at the same time they it
has purpose to it they describe why the
uniforms are the way they are and what
it means in the honor the entry starts
to sort of get into an a stress to be
very proud to wear that uniform uh you
know until they throw it into a dumbbell
joke with Hank say hey nice dress you
know which is cute but I like that they
still they carry that dignity in there
too um and the other thing I'll talk
about
before signing off is that when to start
off with the animals and this uh you
know you say you wanna go penguin
sledding and that's odd and then you see
what penguins are in this world at first
I thought well that's not the penguin
it's penguin like why don't you just
make up a name for it you know I don't
get that but it was until I saw this
episode that I realize you got um they
have these rhinos on the fire ship with
the fire army and I'm saying to myself
why would you how could you keep these
things on there where would you keep
them how would you feed them how would
they get proper exercise kit show so
they bring these rhinos out and they're
these really cool looking creatures
don't have too much of a purpose
watching watching the episode may I do
more in another episode uh but they're
these really cool deform looking
creatures I start asking myself he'll do
other animals look like if that's a
penguin that's a rhinoceros lay that's a
buffalo what the hell else is there in
this world what does a dolphin look like
what does a squirrel look like and it
got me legitimately excited got me
asking questions about the world so
that's actually much more clever than I
give it credit for I that's actually
very very smart
that created a world where they had the
same name but they're going to be
similar design but they're still going
to be different you know I think the eel
you know in the lake there is now a
gigantic monster it's like so wow the
the variations of this are really
exciting and what I realized with this
episode in particular because this one
was a touch more episodic but it is it's
technically continuing the story but
it's obviously a little bit more of a
side episode you know serve with a
little bit more comedy
what I realized watching it is that this
show for lack of a better phrase does
legitimately
make me feel like a kid again it makes
me excited to discover this stuff it
makes me excited to see where it's going
to go next where the relationships are
going to go how they're going to
interact off of all of this what
surprises are around each corner what
you're going to see and what that made
me realize about again for life a better
term sort of grownup entertainment as
opposed to uh
younger entertainment somewhere down the
line when you get older there seems to
be this need to you want to see heavy
drama you want the heavy stuff but we
want Game of Thrones we want loss we
want
characters to die we want things to be
really aggressive we want oh my god I
can't believe they did that you know we
want our soap opera we want sort of this
not that's all negative but we want that
focus on negative cuz that's gonna bring
us back how are we going to get out of
this and you need the likeable
characters but we're more interested in
the really tough situations that they're
put in I kind of forgot you know
watching this it's a reminded me of like
days of like you know back when I was a
kid watching whatever like Disney
Afternoon or some kitty stuff like that
there is this great element of fun and I
forgot that some shows can really
capture that drama in the relationships
and everything else that you see in
really good adult shows but can still
have that element of fun kid shows are
allowed to be fun and I think a lot of
grown-up entertainment focuses possibly
too much on the aggressive um because
there are definitely fun moments and
shows but they're kind of like the side
episodes are the funny little thing
there oh isn't that neat those
characters have this funny little
adventure well back to the serious stuff
um and this show seems to have a really
good mix even though I'm not always on
board with the humor though this episode
was very funny uh they have a real good
mix of it and I just forgot about that
connection and what it means to just
have fun watching a show and I'm having
great fun watching this show and I can
definitely see why so many people are
attracted to it and this is only episode
four so um again very excited to see
because every episode just seems to keep
getting better so I'm very excited to
see where it's gonna go next I know I
always end the V log with that but yeah
I'm definitely I'm not you can call me a
fan I'm a real big fan of this show so
I'll see you for episode 5